je sais que la seule solution qu'on
avait pour survivre qu'en fait moi je me
suis mis devant le fait accompli quand
j'ai un peu commencé mes études je veux
arriver à paris a indiqué que dix-huit
ouais alors la valise de province comme
tous les premiers sur quoi est bon et je
savais qu'avec autre solution mais ça
qu'il faudra peinture autre chose ça je
le savais pas réellement la vie de sa
fille devienne pas que j'étais artiste
que j'avais envie de vivre de ça
principalement être artiste ou pas ça ne
pose est quand est ce que vous avez fait
votre premier table voilà donc un regard
sculptures et en sculpture c'était à
89,82 avoir première premier au sahara
en bonne santé 17 ans limite quand je
faisais des barquettes une fois je vous
avez explosé à quel âge - la première
exposition c'est à dire 1 80 m
j'avais 21 ans et j'ai fait ma première
exposition de groupe donc avec comme
basse reste en place et ça organisé par
le marché indique ainsi que la
parisienne et dans le temps dans la même
année j'ai fait une exposition
personnelle amsterdam a pas traîné
ouais mais bon disons bien une atteinte
aussi à l'époque il s'est passé
tellement rien à le domaine de l'art il
ya une attente nouvelle facture une
nouvelle énergie et on ne voyait que des
morceaux de fil de fer les morceaux
piochés dans les galeries quoi y'a
aucune peinture la peinture existait
plus c'est toi qui vous a le plus
influencé nos laurent avait lui même n'a
pas de justin est un vrai quoi dans
l'europe par exemple le vrai rock au
crâne du moulin le vrai musée du rock
toi moi j'en vois les demandes et les
démêlés c'était ça son utilité quel
peintre torre mais si tu étais pas hervé
di rosa gars comme moi que je sais le
mérite d'être franc jeunesse à venir y
en a beaucoup que j'aime tellement de
fait que j'aime je peux pas le dire quoi
que quasiment tous quoi mais n'arrive
pas à les livrer les choses
intéressantes
tu penses que tu as apporté quoi la
peinture je pense que moi et les autres
et puis il ya aussi moyen comme base on
n'a parlé ni à boire ou conciliables
aïcha on apporte une certaine
décrispation quand on a regardé en fait
de l'appeler ni tueur ça et se casser la
tête sur des tonnes de décrit avant pour
comprendre en fait ne pas être sûr que
tout le monde vous pouvez le regarder et
la maintenance des installations les
parcs notre société on avoue ne pas
ouvrir faisait son aqualand c'est ça
aussi rose à 14h10 rossouw l'eau qui est
aubois qui a ouvert cet été qui ont un
droit ludique où les âmes femmes
faire du toboggan sur des oeuvres
devraient remonter sur les aides renard
marcher dessus tout ça qu'on refuse l
art moderne ne l'arrête et on a apporté
je crois que c'est pas un retour c'est
un problème de retour la figuration
c'est juste un problème d'apporter l'art
contemporaine qui réservaient les
cénacles à une élite la porter vers des
jeunes qui n'ont pas l'occasion d'aller
à la galerie dans des musées qui fait
quand même temps pour faire un tableau
ça n'est pas rihanna que fan trois jours
et là que j'aime et 3 - ouais c'est bien
l'étoffé des grands est en fait de 5,50
survie
la loi est là c'est la dernière expo au
musée d'art moderne il ya cinq toiles
qui faisait 1 42 euro et la fmi m de la
dgrad morceaux là depuis six mois j'ai
fait que dramaturge et je fais à peine
tu râles ha parce qu'un autre le parc
500 m² au sol de faim et puis là où le
sol et le plafond tout est fait ton père
et d'ixelles chapelle sixtine
si ça va mieux si sûr et quand vous
travaillez et écoute quelle musique les
jeunes apprentis buzz paribas
des fois j'ai écouté la radio mais
souvent j'aimerais tout les groupes de
grossesse ouais aironet les christs ça
te plait faire tu arrives to where do we
say say retrait ça me convient un cadeau
d'hervé di rosa aujourd'hui c'est
suivant la taille on en trouve
c'est super la taiwan tous les petits
c'est sûr on n'a pas vers une 4l est une
a relevé joseph aux affaires ça va être
dit me lefranc et puis sur sainte église
tout ça me paraissait pas vous vivez
bien d'autre part tous les deux c'est
pourquoi non ça vous fait conduire par
mois en moyenne fois tu prends un
déclaration d'impôts t'utilises par 12
ouais ouais dans les traces de 49 ans
c'est pas mal ça va au web les contacts
et le marchand et prend combien ils
france 52 pour ça ah bon c'est comme
garros parce que pour moi celui du franc
70 s'il ya un jeu de plus pour quatre
ans à bord aussi se lâchent toutes plus
de vih est véhiculé richert passionnant
chez tous d'accord à bon non je sais pas
moi j'ai que moi j'aurais aux normales
si ça fait rire
on le fait que la peinture aussi ouais
c'est qu'à vannes dans la peinture aux
açores nous on n'a pas peur
heureusement qu'il y aune du warhol à
vannes où on n'a pas peur de dire que
l'art moderne dont le business c'est pas
le but et on sait les ruptures on leva
et voilà aucune zone d'ombré faire en
soit nous quelle fiction l'argent comme
la new love que ce soit ses successeurs
chaillot ses yeux vous vu que l'argent
aille aux orties c'est pour ça que bon
nous on n'est pas à des prix très élevés
il ya des mecs comme des peintres
américains comprennent un buzz très
grave qui atteignent les millions de
francs 45 ans jean gagnon et je pense
qu'il vaut mieux c'est plus juste que ça
ils à leurs proches de la majorité
l'ancien secondeur c'est un bon business
ouais mais à un peu d'élus ouais là vous
vous en êtes en tous les cas pour
l'instant alors est-ce qu'on peut les
voir là léa par le voile alors on peut
voir donc le tas ça parte au grau-du-roi
tous les étés ouais on peut voir dans
l'exposition au musée des enfants du
musée d'art moderne de la ville de paris
donc devenu plus un oui c'est vrai ça
c'est jusqu'au 15 janvier
et puis on peut voir nos oeuvres lala
des peintures et des sculptures donc qu
fiac de la galerie l'aj auxerre au bocal
à la fiac la loi mais alors ça va ça
pourrait aller mieux parce qu'on a on
envie de faire le plus gros encore plus
beau à voir des corrections de nourrir
as they do in a l'habitude abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux